as you can see Mr Bond mommy has been
very bad she told you were deadly when
really you're just a second-rate Steven
Seagal to prove this I placed a shot of
50-year Macallan scotch on her egg take
your shot Mr Bond all right
oh this was stupid the thing I killed
him now as opposed to let him be a
threat later yes that would have been
unbelievably stupid
I could never shoot you classy sweet
pure as gold you are my everything
take it Mr Bond take everything ahead of
you
you are my everything hey sorry baby but
50 years is irreplaceable unless you're
me of course in which case you've been
switched out more times than Doctor Who
I have a secret report from within the
guild four people have come to our
attention regarding a plot that could
jeopardize the sweet actors guild dodgy
prey and his team have refused our
orders to halt their production company
demo reel while they are still small and
unaware of their talent our analysis
indicates there is a danger
I recommend sending several guild agents
to their location to stop them by any
means possible the cheap must blow so
how we doing telltale II they didn't
like this one either it's not that they
hated it I just think they're more
confused why are we mocking the movies
we're claiming to be making better oh
come on
who's saying that everyone we've created
some of the most hated videos online
since that viral trailer of Christmas
story - okay maybe not that bad but I
think it's time we started being honest
with ourselves we have a serious image
problem all right you're you're right
you're right the writing's on the wall I
admit I'm gay I got but that is why I
think our salvation lies in Tampa what's
there a convention a convention why cuz
once a year geeks like to get together
without showering why are we going to
promote ourselves and to remake Lost in
Translation
so let me get this straight you're going
to shoot a remake of a film set in Tokyo
at an anime convention alright that's
pretty brilliant but we're still not
going but how are we gonna get our name
out there Donnie how do I put this we're
the laughingstock of the Internet the
fact that most people don't even know
who we are is probably the only thing
we've got going for ourselves right now
things will change I'm not so sure about
that
what are you to try that Tony Danny I
Donny how we my godson him Elsie are
saying you suck you could've been a
little more diplomatic about it okay
yep no so that's it then all of this has
just been a giant waste of time I
wouldn't say that it's great padding for
my resume Donny come on Donny maybe we
can start over
why it's perfect the way it is you know
ever since I was a kid I always dreamt
about making movies better and you're
destroying them we're not making them
fun we're making fun of them you're
killing the very things that you love
yeah well maybe they had it coming they
were you talking about you're the
investigative journalist you figure it
out
that's not fair you know he's not very
good at that why else would he be here
well if you'll excuse me
Carl and I have a convent er to get to
don't remember agreeing to zette
there'll be beer and how women dressed
in sailor uniform leads the fame and
director
so I'm going to film this movie of that
what the point your back end coma
nobody's gonna like it anyway as
obsessed I said I stopped you know maybe
we should just enjoy the con thicker
desserts I was but I must be a
conference there are many four lines
here I don't think they have much beer
but I'm sure we can get it in somehow
you still have your flask yeah can it
drink four to nine work on that
it's awesome weeks
it just looks sad to me
I know you would love this right
sometimes with my face I think it was a
white car I think it won't
you don't play right
excuse me what what is pocket with
chocolate coating
so it's basically a breadstick dipped in
chocolate
okay sounds like a desert from honey
booboo to make you put rocky I mean do
it with pocket yeah so then from like a
Christmas anima say oh hey give me your
cars are really nice nice for a con if
you want to give me your number that'd
be cool to call me
I think I'm miserable
investigative v-log report Donnie's
become really weird even for Donnie my
attempts to unlock a little bit about
his past I've hit a roadblock
Donnie Duprey does not exist no birth
certificate no records yeah
hello mr. Nero's yeah
do you like remaking movies
well there's some debate about that
actually are even yeah miss stone a
where she actually it's stone the
Ascenta was silent and she's at our
location that's all I needed
wait hey who are you Rebecca
this is Rebecca stone that's stone not
snow day
hi excuse me um you guys still serving
food how can I get an appetizer sure
what you like um can I get a menu
to make you poop Rocky
do it
Jeff Guinness on tap I'll take one
so you part of this whole thing - I
could probably ask you the same question
you are the pro walking around with
pakhi as my latest discovery
surprisingly addictive
I think it's more that it gives your
hands something to always do keeps you
busy now always chewing it a little bit
at a time lord knows I never get busy
I mean I was just going to ask me you
say you're always trying to be busy but
this is a convention do you come dressed
like someone who normally comes to these
shows they don't normally I was actually
coming here to shoot a remake of awesome
translation
what happened with that
you're looking at the problem
you couldn't get this app together you
couldn't get
in a sense what's your name can call me
ugly Oh bad to pray to let me do in
these things
Oh
accidentally created a niche for myself
I'm a geek specific standard comedian so
if I go to a life I'm at a comic-book on
I'll talk about Batman if I'm at a anime
con like these I'll talk about Batman
okay so I mean if you understand a lot
you understand like a lava cauldron
something alright I do a lot of shows
like it okay what are have these people
dressed up it's all right you've got
Deadpool for Marvel Comics again not
Japanese anime but you get it on the
Internet and the Internet is a giant
hodgepodge for everything that you'd
ever want to do I'm serious about Dragon
Balls
I just want to acquire a dress it's
Dragon Ball Z you know they still
attached to the dragon oh they aren't
over do not attach the dragon there Wow
so dragon testicles have magic they
never say out loud that they are
testicles but of course they're hinting
yet all the fans love to embrace you
ever heard of slash thanks kind of is
that where they put two people that gun
belong together together it's a Scully
ex Mulder Kawano said fantasy of mine
I've always dreamt that one day somebody
would do a slash
with them
not you you read to the side of
popularity that suddenly it's like oh
hey people are doing slash pic of you I
mean yeah I think it's weird I don't
even know if I read it but I mean it
just been laughing I know it's out there
is there a flash pic of you
alright investigative v-log I'm heading
over to our location got a really weird
phone call I'm worried about Rebecca uh
I don't know what's going on but um
things have been really weird lately
Donnie's gone off wherever he's at
Rebecca she's alone in
what the hell is this one of those boo
goes from super mario brothers yeah
hell
so you're mr. movie buff if you're going
to if you're going to make lost in
translation are you gonna where you
acting where you directing where you
starring are you working for actors I
usually act in them along with a writer
and also my actors or you know really
good talents to I don't know right tell
them that I mean they're pretty good
does it run in the family
my mother was an actress so that's a yes
so yes do you talk to her much
was she happy that you followed
intercepts I mean was she throw more
what she sent you no I didn't offer you
a pocket they did did you want this one
will make your food especially rockin
okay you got the almond one yes have you
ever heard of the coconut milk coffee
yet there's coconut milk Bakke tastes
just like coconut cream okay I'm going
to plan and escape from this bar so that
we can make our way to the deal with and
we can find some coconut hockey because
that sounds like our en you out
I think I got an Emporium let me
introduce you to somebody oh cool you
know somebody so Christie Ali ate honey
boo boo tragic maybe
Hey ah oh you really are going through
some mid mid life crisis aren't you
really yeah I was afraid of that
you all set to see what kind of life is
about lead the way yeah don't be type of
cleaner heavily no no gumbies very
strictly American but you'll see a lot
of people want to bring by supposing
some theme park imagine Victorian and
today's future done back then so you get
a lot of monocles a lot of Browns now
who's this one dressed up I don't
recognize
almost first I was going to say y'all
got me like from deathnote a gentleman
over in Japan a Osamu Tezuka created
Astro Boy one of the first animals and
he loved the big eye because it looks so
innocent looked so expressive how we
even know how to begin to use this with
you Carl
it's a constantly moon because the
castle we moon us with whiskers
no no she's a reincarnation of a moon
princess all of her team are sort of
powered by plan that's right
could say the same thing about Power
Rangers well because they be right I
will travel across the land searching
far
No
okay
I know
the world we must get back
we gotta catch up
Oh
forget
hey honey it's Donny Donny why are you
calling you know I just want done you
know check out them stuff see how things
are going with I'll be there as usual
hey um have you ever you ever thought
about watching anime
you mean like come on no no like I mean
yeah that is anime but I mean it is a
good anime you know I I didn't think it
existed but there's actually some
there's some real good ones out there
and they're actually somewhat kind of
smart
what well okay there's this one called
princess mana mana he can I think and
it's pretty much about this wolf girl
who's fighting these humans from taking
over the rainforest sounds like captain
yeah I'm just realizing that I'm saying
it but you know what it's actually done
more subtle or like it actually has a
real subtle message which is which is
save the rainforest save the rainforest
yeah okay I know it doesn't sound very
subtle but it's more subtle or I don't
know just it's something about being
down here you know I mean it just makes
me think like I should try different
stuff we should try seeing different
things like even stuff we think might be
stupid well that's mine maybe we can do
that when I'm in town next
okay well then I will just talk to you
later then okay all right I love ya
smart do that
Oh